terrorists hijacked the treatment from
today's festivities I found relying on
the side of the tracks the hospitals
will report realistic full as they were
had little choice but to care you hear
treatment alrighties identified the
alleged mastermind behind the attack an
employee of spurious corporation one
Julius Kresnik Luger Crescent huh you
wouldn't happen to be related to Julius
crystal
what will you do now Hatake me why do
you want to go it came and I can grant
any wish that you make as a place spoken
of in fairy tales an ancient spirit
legends you gotta promise me we're going
to the land of Canaan together
if she's important than see her throughs
even if it means your life I can't drag
you all into this not until you tell us
what's going on Julius
you and I are definitely brothers
the trial is cruel unbearably cruel and
people are weak isn't there another way
Julius do not hesitate act or lose what
you love stop please just stop it will
grant power unless you want it do you
have what it takes what did you do to L
you will come to understand this is our
curse you alone must make the decision
brother I wonder perhaps humans are at
their best when they have someone to
pretend I have to go after L
english
everything rides upon this one choice
not just your life but the fate of the
entire world can you handle its
destruction decision protect that girl
to the end no matter the cost
when I under